[Music]
foreign
I'm the owner inventor and founder of
RedLine Gear cleaning
we are a mobile on-site gear cleaning
company
today we're going to be taking you
through the entire process of what is
involved in cleaning inspecting and
putting fire fighting gear back in
service one thing I wasn't really aware
of when I took the job as a firefighter
was to cancer problem that's played in
the fire service over the last 20 years
66 percent of all on a firefighter line
of duty deaths have been related to
cancer it's not if I get cancer it's
when I get cancer that particular risk
and exposure is something that we really
want to try and mitigate if the
environment is toxic to the point where
you have to wear your air pack that's an
exposure because if your lungs cannot
handle the exposure your gear is
absorbing all those exposures into it
and that needs to be cleaned and washed
so the mobile extraction unit is
actually a patented design that allows
the truck to come directly to the fire
station to be a mobile laundry facility
that specializes in cleaning
firefighting gear contains a water our
electric big commercial extractors
dryers equipment to clean helmets and
air packs all specialized equipment
needed to clean firefighting gear
specifically first step for us is to
assess the firehouse and what that means
could be going Walker to Walker looking
at at the gear determining how exposed
the gear is determining what's in guys
Pockets determining what gear needs to
be cleaned
this helmet is what we like to call in
the fire service salty this helmet is
gross it has seen a lot of smoke it has
seen a lot of contaminants a little
older guys tend to call their gear salty
gear as a badge of honor and they look
at this gear as something that shows
experience and shows they went to a very
hot very involved fire and they got
really dirty that is something that at
redwine we're really trying to change
that culture the badge of honor they're
wearing is causing cancer to these guys
we're trying to tell them that clean is
the new salty
is our ultrasonic machine so as you can
see we're loading the helmets in and
this is what has often been referred to
as our deep fryer for helmets
we use a Degreaser we also use a
sanitizer in here that's going to clean
disinfect and sanitize your helmet to
the point where it comes out we just
have to wipe it down
the helmet is probably the most
important part to a firefighter in terms
of his gear red lines all firefighter
owned firefighter operated so some
people like to say we watch the way all
their experience I like to think we
added a few years of life today
we take a lot of time washing and
cleaning helmets that's probably the
most controversial thing we do as a
company because some people believe that
helmet should never be touched
this gear is particularly very dirty uh
really needs a good deep cleaning from
both the helmet Hood jacket pants liners
all the gear really needs a good heavy
deep cleaning because this gear has seen
a lot of exposure
once we've determined what gear needs to
be cleaned that gear has to be inspected
it has to be separated between the outer
shells and the inner liners completely
separated keeping those wash Cycles
completely different so we don't have
cross-contamination between the cleaning
but while we're doing this we're
inspecting the gear we're looking for
any rips we're looking for burn marks
we're looking for holes in the gear
we're looking for anything that can get
a firefighter hurt
here we have taken the inner liner put
it on our hydrostatic testing machine
this is a process that would test a
moisture barrier of a firefighter suit
to make sure that there's no leaks or
any problems with the moisture barrier
to make sure the water isn't going to
get to a firefighter's skin and cause
steam burns
The Next Step would be to hand clean the
gear we use a product called Decon 7
that we scrub gear to the point where we
get most of the contaminants off the
gear initially
foreign
this is an important part for us as part
of the process to get rid of any bulk
contaminants that would be on that gear
whether it be insulation or anything
else they might run into in the field
a firefighter's gear needs to be cleaned
after every exposure as you can see it
gets pretty nasty
after the inspection the inner liners
are then separated out they're turned
inside out so this way we're washing the
part that is against your skin first
those would then go into our commercial
extractor and be washed through our five
cycle program we use cold water for
washing gear this not only helps the
cleaning process but at the same time it
keeps the colors and stuff in the fabric
true we can fit six sets of firefighting
gear into these machines because they're
so large that's 12 pieces of here going
into each extractor after both the inner
shells and the outer shells clean
through our extractor they then go into
their respected dryers we're able to dry
both the liners and outer shells in one
hour
foreign
we lay out the boots that have to get
hand scrubbed and we are also fogging
them spraying them with a disinfectant
that's going to neutralize it's going to
kill it's going to disinfect anything
those boots might have come in contact
with one of the key elements to a
firefighter gear is the hood they wear
underneath their helmet and go through
that protects their ears that protects
their helmet people forget to even clean
these anything that's going to be
exposed and touched to your skin should
be washed the same way as if you would
the liners that are next to your skin
the water that comes off this extractor
is like a sludge like a mud so anybody
who believes the cancer problem fire
surface isn't real I encourage you to
see the waste water that comes off this
gear it is nasty it is black it is like
mud so at the end of every job it's
important for us to show what the
Wastewater and what the situation is
like in terms of what's coming off the
gear this is the stuff that's coming off
your gear this is stuff we just cleaned
just now that has loaded with soot
loaded with chemicals loaded with stuff
that's causing cancer to these guys we
make it a point to show these filters to
all of our customers to all the
firefighters to know just how dirty
their gear was and how important
cleaning their gear is
our filtration process is so in depth
that it allows us to take really dirty
water filter it run it through a number
of filters run it through a full process
that makes that water completely clean
reusable prevents us from putting toxic
products back into the environment and
makes it a sustainable solution that we
could keep using and be very
environmental safe after we clean very
toxic gear
today the fire service is made up of a
lot of chemicals in the form of
combustion at a fire every single room
is now has Plastics as particle board
has different materials that are burning
it's causing the fires to burn hotter to
burn more violently and the smoke is
thick nasty black smoke so while the
fire service has been around for years
the makeup and the exposures of the fire
service are very different nowadays
[Music]
all right
our final product has taken all 10
pieces of gear that was cleaned putting
it back together putting it in a beer
bag ready to go boots are on bottom
pants jacket hoods and gloves tucked in
the side helmet on the top as one
complete package ready to go
[Music]
we can't control the dangers of the job
but we can control the exposure rate of
what these guys are exposed to from a
cancer-causing substance that's really
killing this fire service I don't need
to see soot and dust all over a guy's
helmet and gear to know he knows how to
do his job I want to see a guy who's
clean got his uniform in shape
everything is properly ready to go he's
able to perform his job to the best of
his ability that's a salty five footer
oh